So let's look at the concept
of image re-projection.
Our interest is being able to take
a scene like this, and capture it on two
different images and more being able to
then, of course, project the information
between those two images to be able to
reconstruct a panorama or a mosaic.
So for the capturing this scene,
imagine I have the first viewpoint,
we'll call it projection plane one.
And this showcases
the second projection plane.
Again, this is the scene
we're capturing.
So what we're interested in
is relating these two images,
which have been taken from
the same camera, and map a pixel
that is in this scene from both PP1 and
PP2.
So it basically means is we now need to
cast a ray through each pixel in PP1,
and draw the pixel where
a ray intersects PP2.
So that means is, this point here,
this is a ray of light.
This is a point here in PP2.
And, of course, this is a point in PP1.
Now in essence,
this is the kind of stuff we learn, we,
we could do with things like,
feature detection, right?
The same feature is
visible in between them,
and now we need to
detect the same feature.
And of course, this implies that this
ray of light is not going through this.
So, rather than to make this
into a 3D re-projection problem,
we will think of it as a 2D image
warp from one image to the other.
What that means is, we're going to take
these two different projection planes,
and think about what would be a work
between these two images that would
allow us to align these two points, even
though these cameras would have moved
as I moved this you know,
took the mosaic or a panorama.
And remember, we're taking multiple
pictures of the same scene and
we're moving the camera a little bit.
So while this ray of light is going
through the same thing, these cameras,
or these viewpoints, are shifted
a little bit, or moved a little bit.
Of course we want to be able to do
this without knowing whole 3D geometry
of the scene, because if you were
to make it into 3D projection,
it would be a little
bit more complicated.